the following is a conversation with
Mark Zuckerberg inside the metaverse
Mark and I are hundreds of miles apart
from each other in physical space but it
feels like we're in the same room
because we're appear to each other as
photorealistic codec avatars in 3D with
spatial audio this technology is
incredible and I think it's the future
of how human beings connect to each
other in a deeply meaningful way on the
internet these avatars can capture many
of the nuances of facial expressions
that we use we humans use to communicate
emotion to each other now I just need to
work on upgrading my emotion expressing
capabilities of the underlying
human this is Alex Freedman podcast and
now dear friends here's Mark
Zuckerberg
that